>> Laura: IT'S TIME FOR ARE
"SEEN AND UNSEEN" SEGMENT WHERE
WE ASK FOR THE BIG CULTURAL
STORIES OF THE DAY.
WE TURNED TO FOX NEWS
CONTRIBUTOR, BACK FROM SOME WELL
EARNED VACATION, RAYMOND ARROYO.
WHILE YOU WERE GONE, BIDEN WAS
DIAGNOSED WITH COVID.
>> I NOTICED, LAURA.
WITH ALL THE NEGATIVE REPORTS OF
HIS GENERAL HEALTH, THE
WHITE HOUSE IS CLEARLY TRYING TO
REASSURE THE PUBLIC THAT EVEN
WITH COVID, BIDEN IS FINE, HE'S
STILL IN CHARGE.
ON FRIDAY, THEY INSTALLED WHAT
APPEARS TO BE A SECURITY CAM IN
HIS OFFICE AND MADE HIM LEADER
MEETING.
>> THIS IS THE 30TH DAY IN A
ROW --
>> ARE YOU FEELING BETTER?
>> THANK YOU GUYS, LET'S MOVE IT
OUT.
>> THAT WENT WELL.
ARE THERE SHOOTING IT ON HIS
BLACKBERRY?
DID THEY TAPE IT TO THE WALL?
THEN TODAY THEY WERE AT IT
AGAIN.
BIDEN HAS NEVER BEEN -- BETTER.
>> HOW ARE YOU FEELING WITH
COVID?
>> President Biden: I'M
FEELING GREAT.
YOU KNOW, I FED TWO FULL NIGHTS
OF SLEEP ALL THE WAY THROUGH.
MUZZLE OF MY DOGS KNOWS ABOUT --
NO, BUT I'M FEELING GOOD.
MY VOICE IS STILL RASPY.
I'VE HAD EVERY MORNING -- EVERY
AFTERNOON -- I GET A FULL-BLOWN
SERIES OF TESTS FROM TEMPERATURE
TO AND THE OXYGEN MY BLOOD.
TO STOP TRAFFICKING IN FIREARMS
ACROSS STATE LINES.
>> Laura: WELL --
>> THEY ARE GIVING HIM PAXLOVID,
THEY SHOULD GIVE HIM PRIVILEGE
IN.
THE POOR MAN -- HE NEEDS HOLES
OR SOMETHING.
HE'S COUGHING, HE'S OUT OF IT,
BUT THIS IS WHAT HAPPENS WHEN
YOU'RE AT 37% APPROVAL.
GOT TO KEEP PUSHING HIM OUT
THERE, AND DISSES ANITA DUNN'S I
GUESS SEARCH AND RELIEF PACKAGE
PROVIDING, JUST KEEPING WORKING
GRADE
>> Laura: RAYMOND, REMEMBER
ONE TRUMP I COVID, OBVIOUSLY HE
HAD TO GO TO THE HOSPITAL, YOU
KNOW, NOT GOOD, BUT MY GOODNESS,
THEY MADE SUCH A BIG DEAL EVERY
TIME HE WAS NEAR ANYBODY -- HE
WASN'T SUPPOSED TO DO ANYTHING,
BUT ARE WE SUPPOSED TO BELIEVE
NOBODY COMES INTO THE ROOM AT
ALL TO KIND OF -- THAT BIDEN
FIGURES OUT THE CAMERA ALL BY
HIMSELF?
I DON'T BELIEVE THAT.
>> HERMETICALLY SEALED ROOMS.
WHAT ABOUT THE POOR DOG?
MAJORS GOING TO GET COVID,
POSSIBLY.
ANYWAY, THE CAPITAL SAW SOME
BIZARRE CLIMATE DEMONSTRATORS
TODAY.
STAFFERS OF DEMOCRATIC HOUSE
MEMBERS CORI BUSH, ILHAN OMAR,
JAMIE RASKIN, AND OTHERS, WERE
ARRESTED WHEN THEY OCCUPIED
DEMOCRATIC
SENATOR CHUCK SCHUMER'S OFFICE.
THEY WERE DEMANDING THAT THEIR
OWN PARTY PAST CLIMATE POLICY
THIS YEAR AFTER JOE MANCHIN
REFUSED TO SIGN THEIR
$2 TRILLION SPENDING PACKAGE.
SIX OF THE AIDES WERE ARRESTED,
AND AT THE SAME TIME, IN
FLORENCE, CLIMATE PROTESTERS
GLUED THEIR HANDS TO A
540-YEAR-OLD PAINTING.
I GUESS DEFACEMENT OF CULTURAL
TREASURES IS THE ONLY WAY TO GET
THIS MESSAGE ANY ATTENTION.
>> Laura: COULDN'T THEY HAVE
JUST GLUED THEMSELVES TO SOME
HIDEOUS CONTEMPORARY ART THAT WE
DON'T CARE ABOUT?
WE ACTUALLY CARE ABOUT THE
BOTTICELLIS.
AL GORE TRIED A SIMILARLY -- I
SHOULD SAY THE MAN KNOWN AS THE
HUMAN DIRIGIBLE TRIED A
SIMILARLY DESPERATE TACTIC TO
PUSH HIS AGENDA.
>> YOU KNOW, THE CLIMATE DENIERS
ARE REALLY IN SOME WAYS SIMILAR
TO ALL OF THOSE ALMOST 400
LAW ENFORCEMENT IN DIWALI TEXAS
WHO WERE
WAITING OUTSIDE AN UNLOCKED DOOR
WHILE THE CHILDREN WERE BEING
MASSACRED.
HEARD THE SCREAMS SCREAMS, THEY
HEARD THE GUNSHOTS, AND NOBODY
STEPPED FORWARD.
>> THIS IS SO DISGUSTING THAT HE
WOULD USE A TRAGEDY IN THESE
CHILDREN'S DEATH TO PUSH THIS
OLD CLIMATE AGENDA THAT HE'S
NEVER BEEN RIGHT ABOUT, BY THE
WAY.
IN 2006, GORE SAID, AND I QUOTE,
IF WE DON'T REDUCE CARBON
EMISSIONS IN TEN YEARS, WE WILL
HAVE A PLANETARY EMERGENCY.
WE ARE WAY PAST YOUR DEADLINE.
STICK TO THE THINGS WE CAN
REALLY CONTROL.
>> Laura: IS IT JUST ME OR
DOES HE LOOK POSITIVELY
PLASTICINE, RAYMOND?
HE LOOKED -- BELIEVE ME, I CAN
HAVE SOME BAD DAYS, BUT HE WAS
UP WET.
THIS LOOKED LIKE SOMETHING --
>> THAT LIGHTING, YEAH.
REFLECTING MOONLIGHT OR
SOMETHING.
>> THAT WAS AN ODD --
>> FINALLY, LAURA, I WAS ON
VACATION LAST WEEK, AS YOU
MENTIONED, AND I'M SO GRATEFUL I
WAS NOT AT DISNEY WORLD.
IT LOOKS LIKE MICKEY'S FIGHT
CLUB.
TWO FAMILIES GOT INTO A DISPUTE
IN-LINE, WHICH THEY CARRIED
OUTSIDE, PUNCHES FLEW, A BRAWL
ENSUED IN FRONT OF CHILDREN, I
MIGHT ADD, AND A FEW OF THESE
KINDLY DEAR PEOPLE WERE
ARRESTED.
OTHERS WERE BANNED FROM THE PARK
AND ASKED THE DISNEY HOTEL.
I THINK I SHOULD HAVE GOTTEN A
MAGICAL TASER AND EVERYONE
SHOULD HAVE BEEN ARRESTED.
PEABODY PROPERTY BAIL, THAT'S
WHAT SHOULD HAVE HAPPENED
>> Laura: THIS IS A FAST PATH
TO FIGHT CLUB.
ME, THIS IS --
>> GO AHEAD.
>> Laura: DIDN'T YOU GO TO A
DIFFERENT THEME PARK?
>> I DID.
WE WENT TO DOLLYWOOD, AND I HAVE
TO TELL YOU, IT WAS -- EVERYBODY
HAD SUCH BEAUTIFUL MANNERS.
IT WAS CLEAN, IT'S WHAT DISNEY
USED TO BE IN THE '80s.
CLEAN, FAMILY-FRIENDLY, PEOPLE
HAD A WONDERFUL TIME BUT THE
PEOPLE WHO WORK THERE, THE
SOUTHERN HOSPITALITY, KINDNESS,
IT WAS EVERYWHERE.
IT'S A BEAUTIFUL SPOT, AND IT'S
MY FIRST TIME IN DOLLYWOOD, SO I
SEE WHY PEOPLE WILL ALWAYS LOVE
HER.
>> Laura: THANKS FOR THE
INVITATION.
THE INGRAM'S USE TO TRAVEL WITH
THE ROYALS.
>> NEXT TIME WE WILL SAVE YOUR
SPOT.
>> Laura: LOOK AT YOU, SO
CUTE!
YOU GUYS LOOK ADORABLE.
I'M GLAD Y